as long as the family's happy the wife
is happy the kids are still talking to
me it's all good sylvester stallone
might now be singing a different tune as
he and wife jennifer flavin call it
quits after 25 years of marriage it's
important to stay together as a family
you can't spend too many weeks apart e.t
can confirm the actor's wife filed for
divorce last friday in florida documents
reveal jennifer wants to remain living
in the couple's 35 million dollar palm
beach home amid the legal proceedings
and get this she's also accusing sly of
hiding marital assets the rambo star
tells et quote i love my family we are
amicably and privately addressing these
personal issues every day is your day
honey you know i wouldn't be here
without you
just days before the split the couple
gave fans reason to believe there was
trouble in paradise
like sly covering up a tattoo of his
wife with new ink the replacement a
photo of the actor's dog from rocky butt
kiss
hey
come here kid come here
to keep your company when you run oh
but a rep for sly says the whole thing
was a misunderstanding quote mr stallone
intended to refresh the tattoo image of
his wife jennifer however the results
were unsatisfactory and unfortunately
unfixable and then there's this cryptic
post from jennifer on august 10th with
her daughters the caption these girls
are my priority nothing else matters the
four of us forever
sly and jennifer tied the knot in 1997
marking the actor's third marriage i
only have eyes for jennifer thank you
the two have three daughters together
sophia sistine and scarlett my wife
raised great great daughters they're
best friends and they really support
each other they fight a lot but in the
end they have each other's backs and
over the years the ladies have made
their way into the spotlight like in
2017 when they were the golden globes
ambassadors
is your dad nervous right now so nervous
he makes me practice in heels for
probably an hour every day
no this morning it's really nice to give
us the nicest pep talk to remember every
single moment fast forward to 2022 and
the entire stallone families shooting a
reality show coming soon to paramount
plus i wanted to call a sly in the
family stone but my daughter said we'll
kill you i thought you know i live a
real a life a weird life funny like
because they're daughters so it's gonna
go down august
no word on how the divorce might affect
the series but fans will have to wait
and see if it will play out on screen
[Music]